[Applause]
so we're out there in arizona we're
cooling chilling by the pool and all
sudden
people start hitting me up they're like
yo chappelle's on
rogan and he's he's uh he's hating you
on you bro he's throwing
throwing shade at you right i'm like
there's no [ __ ] way
did chappelle be throwing shade or even
hating or that
that would even be on his radar right
right so
someone sends me the clip and i check it
out and
uh we let's play it let's play
they're doing things online and like
andrew schultz the best example i think
he started doing those things like
long rants like 10 15 minute rants with
photographs and punchline after
punchline after punchline and then they
did a whole netflix special about it
like he did a series of netflix pieces
on it and what he did was
he said okay i can't do stand-up but
this isn't stand-up so i shouldn't do
stand-up like this because there's no
audience
so the key to this and he figured it out
he's like the key to this is you got to
hit it
fast the punchlines have to come one
after the other
it's got to be fast paced and with
images so like he would use all these
visuals while he was
hitting punchline after punchline oh wow
he figured out a new way to do comedy
he figured out a way to do in internet
instagram
10-minute comedy well okay it was it's
but that's not like you say that's not
stand-up no
like this thing that you're describing
god bless them yeah
that's not what i do yeah it's different
yeah it's different it's different than
the way he does stand up which is
interesting because his stand up is
slower
he he holds laughs he holds pause he
laughs at [ __ ] he [ __ ] around he works
a crowd a lot
his stand up is loose right he has fun
he's comfortable up there
right but his these little clips that he
does on on
instagram are rapid fire bang bang bang
he has works with a series of writers
they all work together they put these
things together they work it out man
by the time it's done it is a polished
machine
but he used that time and innovated you
know and that's clever yeah i don't
think i
yeah it's not i'm not interested in it
because
no disrespect to him i i like happening
in real life
yeah like like even during coba the fact
that we
found a way to get in front of audiences
again meant the world to me
that's what i do yeah it's a different
thing yeah i mean
you know i could throw a slide show and
[ __ ] if i wanted to but that crowd's not
there
[ __ ] point for me i know what you
mean but for him he's coming up still
you know you'd already made it well yeah
get back in there
yeah and it's it's a whole different
ball of wax that's what i'm saying like
that thing that he was that evolution he
was able to make
yes i'm like the old guy who has that
hot outfit from the 70s
go fashion go on without me i look fine
i'm that i'm i'm good with what i
um first of all joe is the man
yeah that was so dope like joe is just
the man and he is like
he's so rare in that
he celebrates other people's creativity
and success
like a lot of people who are even at the
[ __ ] top and you can't go higher
than rogan you know they they still want
to protect what they have so they won't
celebrate
joe's superpower is his lack of
insecurity yeah it is
what he like if i'm interviewing
somebody that's smarter talking to
somebody smart morning i'm joe rogan i'm
gonna always try to put a little smart
[ __ ] in there yeah
i need to come up with a good point
because i'm insecure and i want to be
like well i'm not dumb yeah
don't give a [ __ ] yeah hey you talk i'm
gonna that's why he's a great
interviewer yeah
and this is the same kind of thing where
it's like i'm egoless here's a kid doing
amazing things i love what he's doing
flowers flowers flowers yes on the
biggest stage possible flowers because i
have no insecurity a lot of people
that successful still have that
insecurity like well i can't get flowers
because then they might not think i'm as
dope as i am don't give a [ __ ] yeah so
and you are killing it so he's like yo
andrew killing it
yeah well that's we we're doing it
that's not just me those things mark
worked incredibly hard he wrote them
with me robbie as well
fa you were helping out with them as
well like
miles with the pictures that was a group
effort but it was so dope to see him
give it up and like
if there's one thing that i've like
tried to like continue to pass on that
i've definitely got from rogan
it's like when you see other people
doing dope creative [ __ ] yeah
pass it on and like you know i hope that
we've used this platform to expose you
guys to the new
people that we think are really awesome
and you know i i hope we were doing that
i think we are doing it i think we've
been putting people on i think that
we've been
sharing what we have with other people
that hopefully you appreciate it um
and now to uh to dave uh i actually
let me just give some context this i
think i would have reacted the same way
as dave
given how i was described because
if dave has no clue who i am in terms of
stand up right
and and and joe's describing this like
kind of youtube or instagram comedy
and you know how we all are the second
you tell me about like a funny youtuber
or a funny instagrammer yeah we're like
i don't give a [ __ ] what that [ __ ] is a
little show these stand ups yeah
exactly stand up so this is like i
understand that first reaction yeah
right
and then so i probably would have
reacted the same way in that regard but
then when joe's like no he's a stand-up
it's it's different and
he's he found a way to evolve within the
times
and then i think he was a little bit
dismissive
to it and he was like that's not my type
of comedy that's not what i do and i
guess the only pushback i would give
there
to dave is that like dave is a household
name not
because of stand up yeah but because of
a different type of comedy
and he's still on any list one of the
goats that doesn't change that but you
know
more people know him from chappelle yeah
like sketch show is what made him
yeah a household name like if you think
of like iconic chappelle lines you're
thinking of lines from
yeah i was a dave chappelle santa fan
before the show we loved david as the
standard and it was
there wasn't a lot of people like that i
remember going to see him right before
the show came out
it was he was at a theater but it wasn't
like it was easy to get tickets
right there was empty seats next to us
yeah it's not like he made it
as a household name through stand-up he
didn't make it through stand-up he used
something else and then we found him and
then when we saw his stand-up we're like
holy [ __ ] this guy's [ __ ] prolific
we love him as stand-ups yeah we always
knew how amazing he was
right and current living go yeah and
very few communities break through
just as stand-ups a lot of them will
have a show or something else exactly
yes 100 it's very rare like [ __ ] jim
gaffigan
yeah you know uh some people will say me
yeah because of you
nate bargotsy is another one but um
but look again so i think that he would
be a little bit more i guess maybe
understanding of the other types of
of comedy you know what i mean we all
love the person-to-person interaction
yeah
but like we're also not
multi-millionaires and we can cover test
every single person that comes to do a
show in a barn like
i don't have a barn yeah most people
don't have barns yeah and they don't
have millions of dollars to pay for kova
testing and these types of things so
there were limitations to what we could
do and we tried to work around those
limitations and then
so do i understand the reaction yeah i
think people made too much of it like
there's some [ __ ] bee or like he's
hating on me or a shade or that kind of
[ __ ] like
i really don't think it is that but i
don't know i mean maybe that's just me
i think he caught himself and i've we've
all done this there's nothing wrong with
this you're being a little salty and
then you catch yourself
and i think that's where he said the end
part like i'm the dude at the
in the 70s with the hot outfit like this
is what i do i think
he was like i'm hating okay let me
explain why i'm here let me not hate you
know i think he was thinking i'm kind of
hate and we've all done this where
you're like
i think i'm kind of hating let me check
myself and be real with myself and say
yeah but i'm the you know i'm an older
dude who've been doing stand up 30 years
is what i know
this is what i'm gonna do i think he
caught himself i do
think he knows a little bit about you
for sure us for sure this podcast for
sure dave's a plugged in dude one of the
coolest moments in my life as a stand-up
is somebody telling me this before
flagrant really cracked off somebody
telling me
a story of dave chappelle watching my
heckler video twice watching it once
playing it back for his friends one i
[ __ ] screamed like a [ __ ] groupie
it was the greatest moment
so yeah that's great also and that's to
give dave his flowers
that still means the world to me but
he's also incredibly plugged in
he knows what the [ __ ] is going on he
knows we've had clips where we might
have been critical of certain things he
did
i think we tried to be three-dimensional
and still give him his flowers as one of
the greatest of all time
to me probably the greatest of all time
but i think he was a little bit salty
about that and took one or two shots
and then to his credit checked himself i
was like you know what man i don't need
to do that
i'm [ __ ] dave chappelle right so let
me give my own
with this yeah this is what is what most
people who are
or og's do like joe is the exception
joe's the the og who's like
i want to give everybody flowers like
charlemagne's like that like charlemagne
is the og that like
he just wants to to share and like bring
people up etc and then there are also
some ogs and i got these [ __ ]
tendencies too like everybody's like yo
you got to get on tick tock and i'm like
the [ __ ] am i going to do
yeah and if it ticked off we'd be like
[ __ ] that little guy
and then as a evolutionary thing you're
growing up you'll be like you know what
let me check myself i'm old this is what
i know yeah i think that's what dave was
doing i have no problem with i don't
think he was taking a shot
i think a moment of insecurity is
allowed or a moment of hating or
whatever you call it is allowed and then
he was like
it was funny because joe's trying to
describe like what we do and then dave's
like he's like
that's just not what i do and joe's like
yeah we're not talking about you
i know we're talking about what this
other guy does he's like
but that's not what i do he's like yeah
i know but you already made it
yeah like they're trying to make it yeah
but uh i didn't listen to the whole
build-up
but like it seemed like yeah kind of
similar to what you're saying if someone
were to ask you
like i don't know you like certain like
prank youtube videos or something yeah
but if someone were to describe it and
you hadn't seen it
and they were like oh yeah these guys
they mess with people in the grocery
store yeah like that's not what i do
especially if it's in the in the context
of stand-up yeah and talking about
stand-up and talking about what you do
yeah and someone goes oh you know who
else
does great stuff this guy that does
these prank videos yeah i don't that's
not
like but this is not stand up even
though you actually do like those things
you just
might not have seen it that's what i saw
it as kind of like when i rewatched it
you know
but then when dave then joe was like
correcting it and describing what was
going on and all these things and
all right it seemed like a little bit
you know i'm powerpoint chelsea brad
we out here i think he at the end i
think he came around was like yeah but
i'm also
i'm old i'm the dude from the 70s like
this is what i know so i was like hey
that's
he gave a three-dimensional view of it
in the end he like i wasn't
people put a lot of gas on it i wasn't
cause it's fun
it's fun you put gas on fun i guess and
i guess you could definitely interpret
that way what were you gonna say al
i'm just gonna say um like i agree with
what mark said and also he just talks
like
a goat like imagine yeah mj
kobe yeah and somebody talking about how
somebody else plays he's like yeah but
he don't do what i do
yeah yeah he's like mj said about lebron
you just gotta force him left
like i don't even necessarily take it as
shade it's just like hey i'm just so
focused on what i do yeah like
everything else doesn't matter yeah yeah
yeah
i guess the only pushback i would give
with that is like that that isn't what
you did to get here
you did do other things to get here you
did try to like evolve sketch
yeah you know what i mean you did try
and you had the most prolific schedule
in history
so you would think that there may be
some understanding to comics who are
trying to get to that same
place but but again he might have no
clue what the context is and then maybe
he afterwards goes oh [ __ ] i did see
those things oh now i know what it is so
i can't put too much too much gas on it
um
that's the thing about it it's like as
much as i would love for like one of my
[ __ ] idols and heroes like dave to be
like the biggest fan of the of the thing
like
for me it's so easy to get caught up in
the person that's not
uh maybe enjoying your [ __ ] or doesn't
care or what i guess the word he was
like uh
it's i'm not interested or whatever
but at the same time i got one of my
other idols and my arrows going
oh my god this is great stuff he did the
best thing during the pandemic he's like
i'm gonna choose to
focus my energy there when i was younger
i probably wouldn't be able to do that
and as i get older like man what a
[ __ ] blessing man the [ __ ] go joe
rogan is saying yo we did some amazing
[ __ ] and you know we did the best thing
during the pandemic and
he thinks it's worth bringing up to
chapelle worth bringing up to the live
and go
with comey he was like i don't know for
me that's a i think we should be very
proud of it
yeah and i could check my ego and it is
what it is maybe chappelle will see it
one day and maybe he'll change his tune
and and if he doesn't that's fine too
[ __ ] it you know what i mean i think
i think the takeaway from this is i'm
not going to get a chappelle chain
anytime soon and you know what i can
live with that
i think i'll be okay you know and if
dave wants to rethink that then um
you know we can have that discussion
yeah you know what i mean bro we don't
even get changed though
science [ __ ] up on your part i should
get y'all changed how dare you
you